in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion from May 18, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyrs,
Peter, Dionysia, Christina, Andrew, and Paul.
During Decian's persecution, Peter, a young Christian from Lampsacus, Helispont, of a generous
heart and an ardent faith was arrested and taken before the governor of Abidos.
When the latter commanded him to offer sacrifice to Aphrodite, Peter, mortally offended, declared
that he would never adore a vile prostitute for praise and worship were to be offered to
the true God alone.
At these words, the Magistrate had him stretched on a wheel and bound with chains.
Prices of wood were placed around the wheel so that when it moved, they would hit the
saints' limbs and break his bones.
The truiler that torture became the more ardently the athlete of Christ showed his courage,
and, with a smile of pity for his persecutors, gave thanks to Christ, who was giving him
such power of endurance.
Being himself vanquished by the Marters' patience, the governor finally had him beheaded.
This being accomplished, the governor traveled with a large and mighty escort to Troas,
where three Christians, Andrew, Paul, and Nicomacus were brought before him.
Nicomacus confessed in a loud voice to being a Christian, but was unable to bear the torture
and denied the faith.
He had scarcely finished sacrificing when, abandoned by God, he became the devil's prey,
and seized by an overwhelming fit he gave up his soul to death.
Dionysia, a young girl of sixteen among the crowd, suddenly cried out, oh wretched man,
how could you have drawn down upon yourself for a single hour of life the eternal torments
that no one can describe?
She was immediately seized and taken before the governor, whereupon she confessed that
she was a Christian.
Showing herself unyielding in the face of every threat, she was delivered into the clutches
of two disillute youths.
For long hours they tried to overcome her modesty, but the young girl's guardian angel appeared
as a great, resplendent figure and terrified the impious pair so that they threw themselves
at the saint's feet and begged her to intercede for them.
In the morning the crowd gathered before the palace and, stirred up by the priests of
Artemis, demanded with great cries that Andrew and Paul be handed over to them.
As they refused to sacrifice to the gods, they were beaten with rods and handed over to
the people to be stoned.
By Anicia, hearing the tumult, escaped from prison, ran to the scaffold, and threw herself
in tears onto the bodies of the dying martyrs, crying, to live with you in heaven, I wish
to die with you on earth.
Torn from her companions by force on the orders of the sovereign, who did not wish to satisfy
her desire, she was taken to another place and beheaded.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.